During world war two,
there were a lot of American generals and admirals who commanded combat forces.
They can be roughly divided into two categories,
strategic commanders like Dwight Eisenhower or Chester Nimitz viewed the big
picture of the war, guiding strategy, mastering logistical problems,
and installing the right people in the right places to get the job done.
Tactical commanders by contrast had a more limited focus.
They were frontline battlefield officers often exposing themselves to great
physical danger in order to accomplish their mission.
No officer in the United States better typifies the tactical commanders and
Admiral William Halsey in the dark days,
following Pearl Harbor Holsey commanded the greatest part of what was left of
the shattered Pacific fleet. Having commands of an aircraft carrier task force.
He sought to use this force to bring the war to the Japanese. However he could,
whenever he could,
the standing order was always attack and hit them harder than they can hedge you
throughout the duration of the Pacific war Halsey was in the front lines of many
of the major battles and his inspirational leadership and courage made him a
hero to his sailors and to the civilian population. It wasn't perfect.
You made several key mistakes that might've costed more.
Had he been a less famous commander,
but his contributions to the victory of the United States over Japan were also
obvious to everyone who worked with him.
And he was rewarded for his service with the ranks,
that to date only three other officers in the U S Navy have achieved.
William Frederick Halsey Jr. Was born on October the 30th,
1882 in Elizabeth New Jersey, a large suburb of New York city.
The Navy was in his blood from the start.
His father William Senio was a captain in the United States Navy and an
ancestor.
A captain John Halsey served in the Royal Navy in the American theater of the
war of Spanish succession. 1702 to 1713.
Growing up Halsey was destined to become a Naval officer.
He hits a slight snag though,
when he failed two years in a row to secure an appointment to the United States
Naval Academy at Annapolis,
the Academy is where most Naval officers come from and it was where his father
had graduated from. So it must've been a difficult blow.
He decided to study medicine at the university of Virginia runs become a doctor
in the Navy after graduation. However, after his freshman year at Virginia,
he finally received an appointment to Annapolis and D graduated in 1984.
I'll see Rose rapidly through the ranks. And when the first world war broke out,
he was a Lieutenant commander in command of a destroyer USS shore for his
distinguished service throughout the conflict. He was awarded the Navy cross.
The second highest medal of Valor that the Navy awards.
[Inaudible].
Halsey continued to serve primarily in command of destroyers throughout the
1920s and early 1930s.
But the course of his career changed completely in 1934,
when he was offered commands of the Navy's that aircraft carrier USS Saratoga,
it was only required to complete an observer's course in order to take commands.
But captain Halsey decided to enroll himself in the rigorous Naval aviation
program saying I thought it better to be able to fly the aircraft itself than to
just sit back and be at the mercy of the pilot in 1930 500 seat received as
goals and Naval aviator wings. He was at the age of 52,
the oldest person to do so in the history of the Navy,
he immediately became a leading advocate for the use of air power in Naval
tactics. By 1941, he had been promoted three times device Admiral,
and was the commander of the aircraft battle force of the Pacific fleet
overseeing all three aircraft carriers that the Navy had at pal Harbor.
At the time,
the Pacific fleet was primarily composed of large battleships with heavy guns
and aircraft carriers were considered to be a support ship around 1941.
Tensions with Japan had increased and many felt that war was eminence.
Naval intelligence believed that the small American outpost on wake islands was
going to be a likely target to the Japanese attack in response to this,
the commander of the Pacific fleet and mural Kimmel dispatched,
Halsey aboard USS enterprise to weigh.
He called November the 28th of 1941 to deliver planes to the Marine Garrison
there as reinforcements throughout the journey.
How's he kept a lookout for any Japanese activity intending to attack any forces
that he saw as a threat to his ship, but nothing appeared.
And enterprise started the journey back to Pearl Harbor.
The ship was scheduled to return to port on December the sixth,
but a storm had delayed her,
which means this on the morning of December the seventh,
she was still 200 miles West of us
Confused and desperate, ready, and messages. You told Halsey what was happening.
The Japanese had indeed attacks, but not at wake Island.
They had attacked Pearl Harbor itself in the chaos of that day, come on,
radio Halsey, ordering him to take commands of any and all ships at sea.
The all other ships in the vicinity of Hawaii to rally to the enterprise policy,
deployed his wing,
searching to the South and West of the islands for the Japanese combined fleets
that carried out the Pearl Harbor attack,
but he was unable to locate them as they had retreated to the North Halsey
returns, Pearl Harbor, the next day,
viewing with dismay the damage the attack had done to the Pacific fleet and his
anger. He said before we're through with them,
the Japanese language will be spoken only in hell.
It got Tanika destroyed or heavily damaged all of the large battleships in the
fleet, but Halsey's command was still intact.
USS Saratoga was in San Diego while USS Lexington had departed Pearl Harbor
on December the fifth to bring reinforcements to midway Island.
The carriers were now the only ships the Navy had left in the Pacific to counsel
the Japanese and Halsey intended to use them with approval from the new
commander of the Pacific fleet,
Admiral Nimitz Halsey's ships engaged in his and run raids on Japanese HoloLens,
as the attacks did little lasting damage,
but the American public reeling from a series of defeats didn't cap,
someone was hitting back at the Japanese and that was all the matters.
His sailors who loved the admirals, gruff, demeanor,
and aggressive tactics referred to the raids as holding with Holsey.
It was during this time that Ozzie a quad around their unusual nickname mole,
his life had been known as bill holes. It, you show up for William. However,
in the early months of the war and unknown journalist had accidentally recorded
his name as bull Halsy.
The name actually suited his public persona as he continued to be called this
the remainder of his life though, never to his face.
When he returned to Pearl Harbor. At the end of may, 1942,
Holsey was in poor health, a debilitating skin condition,
which was variously referred to as shingles,
a atopic dermatitis and psoriasis caused a rash to break out over.
Most of his body.
It's believed that the combination of the high stress environments that he had
been in for the last six months combined with his neck,
constant smoking and coffee drinking had aggravated a skin condition.
He had managed for most of his life with creams, unable to sleep,
then having lost 20 pounds Admiral Nimitz sent to order him into a Hawaii
hospital.
[Inaudible].
Halsey was taken back to the mainland United States for treatments being out of
action until September, 1942.
He had missed the crucial battle of midway that occurred in June in which the
Americans sank for Japanese aircraft carriers and largely neutralized that
offensive capabilities for the remainder of the war hoses recommended
replacement,
Admiral Raymond sprue ants that distinguished himself in that battle.
The first step on his own command journey that the war was ends with parallel
Halsey's in October,
Holsey was sent to the South Pacific theater of a scene of a desperate struggle
on the Island of Guadalcanal.
First Marine division has invaded the islands back in August,
but after the disaster,
as battle of salvo islands had seen four Navy cruisers sung and two admirals
killed the Navy had retreated stranding the Marines on the islands without most
of their supplies in the two months,
since then Naval support had been spotty and inconsistent while the Japanese
continued to pour resources onto the islands,
largely unimpeded Admiral Nimitz had concluded that the Naval commander vice
Admiral Robert Romney was overwhelmed and had lost the will to fight and decided
to relieve him of command, replacing them with wholesale.
He was now in command of all forces in the South Pacific and was determined to
take Guadalcanal at all costs where Gormley had been cautious,
Elsie was aggressive. He wasn't afraid to commit his ships to decisive battles,
to stop the Japanese reinforcement of Guadalcanal and to protect American
reinforcements landing. These tactics paid off by February, 1943.
Guata canal was secured Halsey's forces spent the rest of the year attacking up
the Solomon Islands, Jane in particular Borgonville as part of this campaign,
Hulsey directed a daring early morning raid on the heavily fortified Japanese
port of rabble taking the enemy by surprise and inflicting heavy damage in what
was called the American answer to Pearl Harbor. By the end of 1943,
the South Pacific area was largely in the hands of the allies and Admiral Nimitz
had a new assignment for Jose
In 1944,
Nimitz reorganized the bulk of the Pacific fleet into what became known as the
big blue fleet.
This was to beat the fleet that would attack all the way across the Pacific to
the shores of Japan itself to win the war control of the big blue fleet was to
alternate between Holsey and Admiral Spruance,
Jose's friends and the celebrated Victor of the battle of midway while one
Admiral was leading the fleet into battle. The other was on shore planning.
The next campaign,
this allowed the Pacific fleet to increase the tempo of offensive actions around
1944,
in order to confuse the Japanese and make them believe the Americans that even
more ships than they did well, Halsey was in commands.
The fleet was referred to as the third fleet while spoons was in commands,
it was referred to as the fifth fleet Spruance had commands of the fleet during
the first half of the year,
fighting in the Gilbert Marshall and Mariana islands, meanwhile,
Halcyon Dustoff,
which he dubbed the department of dirty tricks back in Hawaii planning for the
most important and ambitious military operation in the Pacific to date,
the liberation of the Philippine islands general Douglas MacArthur had requested
Jose's assistance personally, as he was one of the few admirals,
he was able to work well with a celebrated and also rather egotistical general.
The third fleet, which act in conjunction with vice Admiral Thomas Kincaid,
seventh fleet to provide the troop landings, bombard Japanese shore positions,
and oppose any movement by the Japanese fleet. On October the 20th, 1944,
American troops led by MacArthur landed on the islands of late and quickly
pushed inland to the Japanese high command. The situation was dire.
If they lost control of the Philippines,
they would lose their fuel pipeline from the Dutch East Indies back to Japan.
And they would run out of oil to power their Navy and air force and short.
If they'd lost the Philippines, they would lose the war. They put into motion,
an operation. They called Shogo one and almost all of their remaining ships,
steam to the Philippines, setting up what would be the largest Naval battle of.
[Inaudible].
Was to split their forces into three groups, Northern Southern and center force.
The Northern force had almost all of the Japanese Navy's remaining carrier
forces,
and it was supposed to lure Halsey's third fleet away from late aid to the North
as a diversion.
Then when the Southern forest kept to the seventh fleet occupied the powerful
center force headlines by the two largest battleships ever built Yamato and
Masashi would be free to steam unopposed to the landing positions later,
where they would sink troop,
transports and bombard the American troops on shore disrupting and perhaps
stopping the invasion entirely American submarines detected the movements of the
Japanese,
sent a force on October the 23rd and reported it to Halsey who deployed as our
wings in response.
What we'd like to be known as the battle of Leyte Gulf was actually four
separate battles in the waters around later.
The first engagement was the battle of SIBO Yancy on October the 24th Aussies
carrier aircraft attached to the center force commanded by Admiral Taiki.
Corita inflicting heavy damage on it,
including sinking the massaging Corita town districts around.
So it got away from the aircraft and Holsey believes that he was retreating and
was no longer a threat at the same time.
Third fleet scout planes protected the Northern force and Halsey tenant,
his fleet to engage them.
What he didn't know was that the Northern force was the diversion that the
carriers in the Japanese taskforce had few planes or air crews to threaten
Halsey's fleet. They also didn't know that during the evening of October,
the 24th Corita reversed course and steam does center force through the San
Bernardino straight.
This was towards the landing zone on the East side of later,
the third fleet had two main components to it, taskforce 38,
which consisted of the aircraft carriers and task force 34,
which consisted of a group of powerful battleships.
The seventh fleet commanded by Kincade believed that Halsey was leaving
taskforce 34 to cover the San Bernardino straight taking only at taskforce 38 to
attack the Northern force. As a result,
Kincaid deployed his entire force to attack the Southern forest decisively
defeating it and the battle of surrogate straight, uh, vicious,
nighttime battle. That was the last time in history,
battleships 40 each other directly,
but how she had made a fateful decision taking the entire third fleet do attack
the Northern force and leaving the San Bernardino straight completely unguarded
Kincaid didn't realize until too late.
What had happened and was too far away to intervene.
When on the morning of October, the 25th,
the center force consisting of four battleships,
eight cruises and 11 destroyers steamed into the Philippine sea off the Island
of Somar they're only American ships in the area was task group 77, four, three,
known as taffy three,
a group of small unarmored escort carriers protected by screen of destroyers
taffy three was designed to act as close as support for the ground ribs and
attack submarines knots, engaged capital ships and pinched battle.
But the commander of taffy three rear Admiral Clifton sprog knew that he needed
to buy as much time as he could until how Siegel King cage could come to his
aid. So he engaged, courageous,
sent a force with everything he had the battle of summer.
Also known as the last stand of the tin can.
Sailors was one of the most lopsided battles in Naval history,
at least on paper. It is also considered one of the U S Navy's finest hours,
taffy three Fort ship,
several times the size of their own doing an incredible amount of damage for
American ships Johnson. Samuel B.
Roberts hole in Gambia Bay was sunken over 1,500 sailors were killed a figure
representing half of the total American casualties of the entire battle of
Leyte Gulf. So not the engagements at mural.
Kincaid sent a string of urgent calls for help for taffy three to Halsey,
but how's,
he continued to steam his fleet North away from center force back in Hawaii,
Admiral Nimitz was trying to understand what was going on.
He sent a message to Halsey asking where taskforce 34 was messaged ended with a
nonsense phrase. That didn't mean anything designed to confuse the Japanese.
You might be listening in, but the sailors on board house,
these flagship forgot to remove the phrase from the end of the message before
delivering it to the Admiral. As a result of the message Chelsea received said,
where is taskforce? 34,
the world wonders Halsey who had a fiery temper at the best of times,
lost his head completely. It,
what he viewed as a stinging rebuke from his commanding officer.
He threw his house on the grounds and began swearing violent, and the alarming,
everyone on the bridge of his flagship,
his chief of staff rear Admiral Connie yelled at him to get ahold of himself and
Holsey calmed down.
But it would be another two hours before he finally ordered taskforce 34 to turn
around and go to taffy three's eight. But by the time they arrived on the scene,
the Japanese center force was gone.
Admiral Corita had met such ferocious resistance from taffy three that he became
convinced he was fighting Halsey's third fleet and withdrew before he could
accomplish his mission to disrupt the landings.
A few hours later holds these carriers engaged Northern false in the battle of
Cape and Ghana sinking all four remaining Japanese aircraft carriers.
The battle of Leyte Gulf was a resounding American victory.
The Japanese Navy was effectively finished as a fighting force.
The remaining ships in their fleet returned to Japan and would not Saudi again
in such a force for the rest of the war.
The whole CS tactical mistake referred to as the wholesale blunder roll bulls
run had colored his reputation quite a bit.
His pension for aggressive action had worked against him.
If it hadn't been for the heroic efforts of taffy three,
the Americans could have met with disaster.
Halsey would spend the rest of his life,
defending his actions at later golf and attacking his critics
And took another hit in December.
When the third fleet was inundated by the powerful typhoon Cobra,
Halsey believed the worst of the storm was going to pass to the North of his
fleet and ordered his ships to remain on station.
By the time he realized his mistake, it was too late.
The ships were in the teeth of a vicious tropical cyclone,
which caused three destroyers to sink over 100 aircraft to be washed off the
deck of his carriers into the sea. And it killed 800 sailors.
Kelsey faced the court of inquiry about his conduct regarding the typhoon,
which stopped short of fully sanctioning him, which would have ended his career.
Still. The storm became known as Halsey's typhoon among the third fleet sailors.
As the enlisted men began to view the Admiral, his reckless incredibly in June,
1945, Holsey again sailed his fleet through a storm typhoon Connie,
which did even more damage to the fleet.
The second court of inquiry recommended Halsey be reassigned,
but Nimitz refused still loyal to one of his most trusted subordinates that
ultimately did a matter as the Japanese surrender to the allies in August ending
the war Hosea was present on the USS Missouri for the formal surrender of Japan
in Tokyo Bay on September the third, 1945 in December, 1945,
president Truman selected Holsey to be promoted to the five-star rank of fleet
Admiral one of only four officers in the history of the Navy to attain this
rank.
He stepped down from active service in 1947 and later joins the board of the
American cable and radio corporation serving until 1957. I don't know,
Holsey died on August the 16th, 1959 at the age of 76.
His body laid in state at the Washington national cathedral,
and he was buried at Arlington national cemetery. America's foremost,
military cemetery.
William Halsey is one of the most important figures in world war two.
He understood early on the importance of air power in the war against Japan,
and that the best way to recover from the attack on Pearl Harbor was to use the
Pacific fleets aircraft carriers in an aggressive manner to take on the
Japanese.
This focus on see based app power was not only instrumental in winning the
Pacific war, but it continues to form the basis of American Naval doctrine.
Almost 80 years later.
It is perhaps a shame that his decisions during the battle of Leyte Gulf have to
a large extent overshadowed his accomplishments from earlier in the war,
but it was perhaps the price the Navy had to pay for having an aggressive
commands like Halsey and command. One thing is for sure though,
if Admiral Halsey had not been in command of the Pacific things would have
turned out much differently. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe brand new videos several times a week. And as always.
[Inaudible].